many people across the valley are
celebrating juneteenth today the now
federal holiday marks the end of slavery
in the u.s jeremy j ford takes us to
decatur and sahara where a push to
promote black businesses happen today
i'm here inside the art house hookah
lounge where black business owners are
celebrating black excellence this is
because of juneteenth and because of the
celebration and who we are as a people
it has allowed me even to be here today
gracie egami owns her very own skin care
company and came to the juneteen
celebration to showcase her products
we've been actually serving the
communities for 15 years with our
organic skin care line to help them to
condition their skin repair and to
revive their scan back to help massage
therapist taisha jackson also came out
to promote her business it gives me an
opportunity to meet other people
like-minded entrepreneurs and
business owners it's also a great
opportunity to celebrate black fathers
especially on the day for emancipation
and on father's day at the same time
robert garner tells me he decided to
host the celebration to promote
community relationships and positivity
what i wanted to do was give back to the
black community and i figured there was
no better way than to
bring more attention to small black
businesses and keep the money rotated
within our community an opportunity that
young fashion designer denzel tillman is
capitalizing on i want my shirt to be in
stores hotels so it could be kind of
like souvenirs for people who come into
vegas jeremy j ford live local now
now some closures to be aware of
tomorrow as we observe juneteenth post
offices will not be open which means
regular mail services are delayed until
tuesday most banks in the stock market
will be closed as well along with
federal government buildings and offices
las vegas and north las vegas have also
sent out notices that they're closing
most city services